like Oh Caputo is a former advisor to
the Trump campaign 2016 and he's been
through the wringer in the last couple
years he joins us tonight
Michael you watched the sentencing
against this the secondary the second
round of sentencing for Paul Manafort
today and you saw that one of the
charges that he pled to was not
registering the foreign agent
Registration Act of 1938 something that
basically nobody in Washington does did
you begin to wonder maybe if this was a
selective prosecution Wow
yeah I guess so I mean lets you Tucker
nobody knows more than you that you know
then left views absolute annihilation as
victory they'll stop at nothing to
achieve it you know they'll they'll try
and get you fired try and silence you or
they'll try and like in my family you
know try and ruin your family or even
throw your dad in jail you know but in
the meantime Paul Manta Ford's go to
jail for a registration charge and he
partner on the Ukraine project where he
was supposed to be breaking the law was
Tony Podesta and as far as we can tell
Tony Podesta hasn't been indicted so
even a blind person can see what's going
on here
there was Tony Podesta registered under
the foreign agent Registration Act of
1938 I don't think he was wasn't no it
was not that when when manna for it was
was called on it so was Tony and they
both kind of extemporaneously registered
for it and they thought that was fine
for Tony but doesn't I guess it didn't
look too good for Paul Manafort you know
it's it's outrageous and and and now
that we seem you know at least a page is
testimony and everything this is
becoming more clear than you know than
we've ever imagined that would be it
would become but look you know the the
manna fort I'm sorry the mole report is
supposed to be coming to a close and my
family's had our lives on pause for two
years along with dozens of other
families you know 81 other people
learned this week or last week that
enough they wasn't over in the house
either
chairman Adler appears to be starting it
all over again asked us all for
documents and it appears that it's going
to be a long long summer with 81 people
being marched in front of the House
Judiciary Committee are you going back
oh I won't go back I gave them a quick
answer me and my attorney to their
question four documents we have no
documents that that they asked for we I
also have the shortest document request
of all 81 people but they still ask my
my attorney if he would present me for
testimony and if they're inviting me
they're inviting all of us and I can't
listen at the end of the day Tucker
we've talked several times about this
ISKCON I've been doing this for two
years it's a long dance I've testified
three times under oath each time to the
same questions each time it cost me half
a year's salary and here we go again
just when my family was waiting to press
play on our lives right and if you know
I got nothing left they take taking my
business they've they punched a living
crap out of my family I got nothing left
so what are they gonna take from me but
my freedom and the only way they're
gonna take my freedom for me is if I
testify a fourth time under oath and
they get so you know they tear me apart
like Democrats are want to do I'm not
willing to do that so I'll take the
fifth and I'll keep doing it as long as
my families GoFundMe holds out on Uncle
Famicom we'll keep doing it I think some
of the other 81 people should do it as
well you know you're in that what's
gonna remind you and I'm hoping people
stand up behind me so I guess the lesson
is you should have worked for Jeb or
John Kasich I don't see the feds going
after anybody who worked on the Jeb
exclamation-point campaign or John
Kasich just notice I mean that you know
I'm sure it's not connected well I mean
Jeb took money from the Chinese over a
million dollars into his affiliated hack
so I don't see anybody asking them about
that but here we go again with the
Russia Kaluza believe him and by the way
you saw just yet yesterday chairmanship
who's missing all the headlines on the
camera time he's saying if Muller's
report doesn't come in and it had and
has the president you know live tweeting
some question and answer with Muller
he's going to start the whole thing over
again all he's saying is if you don't
release the Muller report we're gonna
rip everybody like Caputo
apart limb from limb that's what he's
doing it's really we're gonna look back
on this in horror and shame I think
Michael Caputo good luck